brian the clark county school district
is ramping up its hiring efforts as we
continue to deal with a massive teacher
shortage here and across the country
sasha loftis joins us with more on the
district's new hiring campaign and what
it could mean for the future of our
local classrooms denise the district
really is thinking outside the box here
to hire the teachers they need we spoke
with a young woman today who's taking
this different route to score her dream
job
i don't consider it a job i consider it
a passion gerania mancia has a talent
for teaching
from the beginning she's worked as an
assistant at ronald elementary since she
graduated high school once i started
that helped me actually
know that i wanted to be a teacher now
she has her sights set on a teaching
license and is taking classes while she
keeps her current job to make that
happen would you like to share your
experiences rachel ratan is a teacher
and training instructor at rancho high
school we've done so much she spends her
days preparing high school students for
careers in education we need teachers we
not only need teachers we need great
teachers it's all part of ccsd's you
grow we grow recruitment campaign to
ramp up hiring and combat a chronic
teacher shortage the district's website
lists just over 1300 teacher openings
for the upcoming school year and ccsd
recruitment director stephen flack hopes
to find those candidates here locally
trying to figure out ways that we're
going to improve how many teachers we
produce here in the state future
teachers just like durania who says
she's eager to commit to this next phase
of her career i know
they need the people out there so i'm
actually trying so hard to finish
ccsd's recruitment director says in
addition to the 1300 open positions for
next year they have about 77 current
teacher openings we have more
information on this recruitment campaign
on our website 8newsnow.com